I never wanted to make this video tanah
mojo responds to Billy Eilish doing the
unthinkable unfollowing her on Instagram
I know Billy unfollow those people and
then refile those new people to keep her
following at 666 but I just I didn't
know when the party was gonna be over
you know Tana has made it very clear
she's a huge Billy stand she even made a
video in which she dressed like the
singer for a week and bowed down to her
when they met at one of Billy shows last
year really grateful for them but the
relationship between the singer and the
YouTube creator seems to be disappearing
just like Billy's follow you know before
really follow yeah just the incident
seemingly occurred after Tana asked the
singer through direct message whether
she'd be attending her Las Vegas wedding
to fiancé Jake Paul which Billy simply
replied no in the video we see at Anna
coping with the sad reality that Billy
called it quits on their social media
relationship drinking wine lots of wine
while cleaning her house and fridge in a
Billy Eilish tea and oversized cozy
sweat suits one of Billy's go-to fits to
rock
[Music]
unruly downfall of tibi Tana and Billy
may stem from when canna actually got
engaged - Jake Paul back story the
internet went nuts in June when Jake and
Hannah confirmed and Billy did not hold
back her thoughts on the engagement
commenting under a pic of the couple
shortly after they shared the news twice
writing eke and Yeates
[Music]